hello good afternoon everybody we're so
happy to see you here
um I'm just going to say a few words
about the park lecture the song Young
Park and Margaret Clark Park Memorial
lecture was made possible by a generous
gift from their estate
the principal objective of this gift is
to Foster the study of Korea at Yale by
bringing recognition of the Korean
Peninsula and its Affairs and
achievements both to Yale and to The
Wider community
the parks met at Yale and were married
in 1964.
and in an interview Park gave in 2002 he
said that coming to the United States
and studying at Yale was an experience
that shaped his entire life
Park earned his PhD at Yale in 1965 and
then taught economics at the University
of California Berkeley
in 1968 he returned to Seoul to work as
an economic advisor to the president of
Korea
and he also taught economics at
University
in 1984 he took over the Helm of kung ho
after his father who was its founder and
chairman passed away
Park continued to build this
Transportation construction and
electronics company
establishing Asiana Airlines in 1988 and
thereby forming the Kumho Asiana group
the inaugural Park Memorial lecture was
by Victor cha professor of government
and international Affairs at Georgetown
University
Carter Eckhart Jung SE young Professor
of Korean history at Harvard University
gave the second Park lecture and Jin Y
Park professor of philosophy and
religion at American University gave the
Third
and today it is our great pleasure to
welcome Laurel Kendall
who is our first Anthropologist to give
the park lecture at Yale so thank you so
very much
okay thank you so much for coming my
name is Juan sukem I teach Korean
religion culture in the department of
relative studies and it's great honor to
introduce our speaker Dr Laurel Kendall
Dr Kendall is um the curator of Asian
ethnographic collections at the American
Museum of Natural History and a senior
research scholar at the Weatherhead East
Asian Institute at Columbia University
and also a former president of the
association for Asian studies in 2016 to
2017.
she earned her ba from UC Berkeley as
well as her 2ma and a PhD from Colombia
she is an uncontested unparalleled
Authority on the subject in Korean
Shamanism and her broader research
ranges from Shamanism and gender
relations and religious practice and
material religion in East and South East
Asia
Kendall begins began her passion for
Korean studies when she was working as a
Peace Corps in 1970
when I was born
and she encountered several female
shamans on through their ritual
performances and this encounter led her
to three decades of anthropological
field work resulting in three
groundbreaking monographs
first Shaman's Housewives and other
Restless Spirits women in Korean ritual
life published in 1985
examines Korean female shamans with a
special focus on gender relations
her second book life and hard times of
Korean Shaman published in 1988 details
the life of a Korean Shaman Young's
mother who became a close Implement and
her friend but who passed away last year
unfortunately
lastly Shaman's Nostalgia and the IMF
South Korean popular religion in motion
published in 2009 traces the evolution
of Korean Shamanism from being
disparaged as Superstition in the 1970s
to be to be embraced as a religion and
ultimately being loaded as a fundamental
part of Korean culture in the 1990s and
actually I have been using this book for
over like 10 years for my class religion
culture in Korea
in addition to her expertise in Korean
Shamanism Dr Kendall has also published
the book on gender titled getting
married in Korea in 1996. this book
concerned how much is that made wedding
rights are conducted and families
finance and carry out the recorded
exchange of ceremonial Goods in South
Korea
the book shared lies on the changing
material not Material marital roles of
Korean women you know Society rapidly
transformed in the late 20th century by
industrial capitalism and the emergence
of a full-blown consumer culture
Dr Kendall's most recent work concerns
the production and consumption of sacred
objects in contemporary market economies
and she has conducted extensive field
work in South Korea Vietnam Myanmar and
Bali
and this research resulted in a book
mediums and magical things statues
paintings and masks in Asian places this
book was published in two years ago in
this book describes how material images
give form and presence to otherwise
invisible entities
and how sometimes these objects are
understood to be enlivened agentive on
their own terms
in addition to our five monographs Dr
Kendall has also edited and co-edited
six volumes it could be more
and also at the American Museum of
national history she has curated several
exhibitions including Mythic creatures
dragons unicorns and mermaids in 2007
and Vietnam Journey so Body Mind and
Spirit in 2003 and the second exhibition
was a unique collaboration with the
Vietnam Museum of ethnology that earned
Dr Handel a French medal from the
Vietnamese government
and although I have
um respect your scholarship for a long
time this is the first time I have had
the pleasure of meeting in person in
fact in addition to today's talk
um Dr Kendall has kindly agreed to give
a keynote speech at the upcoming iwa and
Yale conference in Seoul scheduled for
May 27 6th and after the conference um
all the participants including Dr
Kendall and I uh will have a week-long
trip in South Korea field trip including
places like tejudo Busan and kyungdu and
my colleagues and I are very looking
forward to our spending ample time with
her it's so wonderful to have you here
today please join me welcoming Dr Laurel
Kendall
[Applause]
thank you Dr Kim for that gracious
introduction and I considered a great
honor to be here today as part of this
distinguished lecture series
I this talk introduces oops sorry got
ahead of myself this talk introduces the
comparative project I will be looking at
Korea but not just at Korea Vietnam is a
part of it
there will be a few words about Myanmar
and also Bali Indonesia
the project resulted in a book with
Burmese nut spirits on the cover
IT addresses a challenge posited by
Anthropologist Webb Keane he says
here is anthropology here you have an
innately comparative discipline it's
been comparative from the moment of its
birth
and yet
anthropologists today are absolutely
squeamish about doing overtly
comparative work
we are embarrassed by the inscriptions
of our Victorian forebears and not happy
with the supposedly controlled
comparisons of mid to late 20th century
anthropology a bid to be scientific with
what we're in the end apples and oranges
insufficiently contextualized by their
roots and trees
if I could do anything differently in
the final chapter of my first book well
it would probably be to not write the
Final Chapter which is a place where I
attempt to make a gendered comparison of
rituals Gods ghosts Purity and pollution
in Korea China and Japan
in ways relatively innocence of
historical geographical and class
variation
within Korea China and Japan
it was the big statement I needed to at
the time to get a publishing contract
but in retrospect a mistake
I will stand by the rest of the
ethnography between these covers but
chapter 8 is an embarrassment an
artifact of another time
I have worked with Korean Shaman since
the 1970s and I have continued to write
books about them
the project that I am going to share
with you this evening begins in Korea
it begins with Munchen who are who I
would translate them as shamans not just
Spirit mediums but shamans masters of
the spirits while a medium could be
considered something of the spirit's
puppet possessed entranced taken over
mention our agentive
they are expected to win the Good Will
of the Gods to pacify ancestors on
behalf of their clients to mollify
Troublesome spirits and cast things
impure away from their clients path so
that is open to blessing and good
fortune
their primary work is accomplished in
costumed rituals called
where they are empowered to make the
gods and ancestors a living and speaking
presence
the gods of the shamans Pantheon are
invisible but they become a visible
presence in two ways one they are
through them the munchens visible
manifestations in quit their mobile
their vocal but this is a temporary
presence
permanently present in the painted
images that hang above the Shaman's
altar more constant but as we shall see
not completely constant
the paintings were backdrop to my early
work but I did not have occasion to
think very much about the images that
hung above the munchen's altar Beyond
understanding that these were sacred
objects that They Carried the identities
of the Gods in the Shaman's Pantheon and
that they were consequential for the
munchen's work
I did hear a story about some paintings
of old gods hung behind the altar of the
Munchen I call yongsu's Mother
her sister was also a mansion but her
sister wanted to give it up because her
sister's son said live with us but you
can't be a munchkin if you live with us
she had dreams she made prayers it
seemed like the gods that she served
were quite willing to go over to
yongsu's Mother's Shrine and work with
her and her Gods now the shrine was a
very narrow space
and so yongsu's mother took the new
paintings and put them under the old
paintings this was after they did all
the appropriate ritual and the God said
yes yes yes we'll be here we'll work
with you we'll help you and so she puts
them one under the other
and then things go south
she has illnesses she has a falling off
of business her clients aren't coming
with the usual regularity or they're
coming for a divination and they're
going to another munchkin to have them
do the more expensive ritual
and she's having trouble getting a flow
of inspiration from the gods who are
above her altar
and then she has troubling dreams
now in one dream some women come to her
for a divination
three women and one of them sits down
the shaman she does what a Munchen does
when she's about to give an inspiration
she brings out a tray there's rice
screens on it there are coins she's
going to throw the rice throw the coins
through the configuration she's going to
get some sense of what's going on with
the client she'll ask more pointed
questions until she get does a full
diagnosis
um she's doing this empowered by the
deity UC at the Divination tray in the
picture the great spirit grandmother who
in individual Munchen pantheons is
usually
um a an ancestrous or a teacher Shaman
some Shaman in her past who is guiding
her in a lineage type way
um
so the women come in and one woman sits
at the other side of the tray and the
other two she says sit down sit down you
know and they say no they stand by the
door and she feels very uncomfortable in
the dream you know that these women are
just standing scowling and then one of
them
stalks over takes hold of that tray and
upends it on the floor and she wakes up
and she feels really bad because this is
the rice that belongs to the great
spirit grandmother and it's it's like
she's been violated her primary deity
has been violated so she goes right into
her Shrine room and lo and behold the
paintings of the her own great spirit
grandmother and the painting of her
sister's primary deity the Jade Immortal
they've
stuck together and Fallen to the floor
and she says they'd been fighting
I thought fighting who's fighting God's
fighting God's paintings fighting
fadings God's fighting each other
through the medium of paintings and I
didn't know what was going on
and I put the story of the Fallen
paintings aside
it remained like a nagging itch I would
come back to it
and I'm going to put it aside for now
and come back to it
fast forward and a move to the north of
Vietnam early in the New Millennium
where in my work as a character at amnh
I had an opportunity to work with the
Vietnam Museum of ethnology
now we were doing an exhibit called
Vietnam journeys of Body Mind and Spirit
and we had various Journeys in it and we
thought well let's include Spirit medium
Journeys and we can include the mother
goddess tradition which is very rich and
colorful and fusai Temple the main seat
of mother goddess Worship in the north
of Vietnam
donated to the museum for the exhibit
the three statues that you see in the
back there
and they saw this as an attempt to
introduce the world to their religion
which had been suppressed under Sandy's
Superstition campaigns but was back and
flourishing in the new Vietnam
and then 9 11 happened
and suddenly uh you know there was a bit
of an economic crisis in the wake of 9
11 the American economy had actually
been sliding a little bit before and we
were told you've got to cut your exhibit
by a third we just don't have the money
and the statues which I hadn't really
met yet seemed like very good candidates
for cutting because they were big heavy
Fragile the only way we could safely get
them to New York would be to buy seats
for them on the airplane
um
so the statues were cut what do we use
in their place
and we felt we should consult with
Spirit mediums at fusai Temple so Madam
zwin the wife of the shrine keeper very
formidable Spirit medium in her own
right was going to come and talk to us
at the Museum and she was not happy that
we were not going to use these
spectacular statues now the statues have
been kept in storage and they've gotten
a little Dusty so the conservators
meaning to do a good thing took them
outside put them on a low platform and
were dusting them and we were standing
around saying gee they're beautiful
they're so beautiful and Madam zwin
arrives and she walks in she sees the
conservators at work and she says you
put them on the floor would you put Ho
Chi Minh on the floor how can you do
that and profuse apologies ensued now my
colleagues were surprised by her
reaction because they understood as I
did not understand
that Holy images like these statues in a
temple setting they would be animated
with the spirit essence of the mother
goddesses or a Buddha or whatever but
that these had not been animated that
they were as they understood it just
statues and yet you know they were
something more than just statues and we
wanted to find out
um
now the mother goddess tradition of
Vietnam interested me as it interests
anyone who knows Korean Shaman practice
because again you see the elaborate
costumes you see the sequential
appearance of the Gods you see a
mimicking of Royal dress and hierarchies
of gods that parallel temporal
hierarchies of kings and officials and
so on so I really wanted to learn more
about it
um and in 2004 thanks to the winner
Grand Foundation my Vietnamese
colleagues and I were able to do a
further study
um
and I went back to fuzzai Temple and
talked to the temple keeper and talk to
you know about tell us tell us what
these statues meant
and tell us why it was so wrong to put
them low down to try to clean them when
there are poor conservators thought they
were doing a good work
and um and then we went beyond fuzzai we
talked to other mediums we talked to
Carvers we talked to a lacquered maker
we talked to people who sold statues in
the market
and um at the start of many interviews
just to explain what we were about I
told the story of the paintings in Korea
that had fought with each other and
Fallen to the floor and this was a very
good move because this banished any
perception that me as an American was
going to look down as superstitious all
this stuff that was going on
um and that I was open to the idea that
images could do things like fight with
each other and cause bad luck
and this was the beginning of my
education in magical images and the
start of a comparative project that
would event ually draw in Myanmar and
Bali and draw me back to Shaman shrines
in South Korea and the matter of the
Fallen paintings
in Vietnam we were interviewing Carver's
Spirit mediums ritual Masters Etc at a
very good moment
because
under high socialism there had been many
acts of iconoclasm the consequences were
very fresh in people's minds you know
they threw the statues in the pond and
somebody died in a flood and and this
woman who was telling me this says and I
have chronic arthritis you know if only
we hadn't done that to the statues
also the market was back things were
looking up and there was a felt need for
uh to repair to restore the Fallen
statues to repair decaying temples so
statue carving was very much on people's
minds
now
all of my life
all of my adult life I have been bowing
to Buddhas showing respect I've been
guided in my form by many Korean women
um
I never realized that the Buddha was
supposed to really be there until I
began doing this work
I was learning what my Vietnamese
colleagues knew very well that through
ritual acts the statues had been made
into social entities after being
ceremoniously placed on the altar the
cavity in the Statue body would be
filled with animating matter sometimes
regarded as an approximation of human
organs
amulets and and other things and then on
a lucky day in the dark Midnight Hour of
the rat a ritual master or a monk would
bring the statue to life Awakening its
senses opening its eyes
now we studied the we studied that you
know what do you do to make the statue
alive but we also studied the protocols
for making
this statue what the Carvers and the
spirit mediums considered necessary to
make a powerful statue and then the
statue's subsequent careers
when I searched the literature
specialized studies from India from
China from Japan I was surprised by how
widespread these ideas seem to be that
the image is transformed by ritual
action into presence and that the
presence becomes consequential
and I was tempted into further
comparative work building my own
questions upon an existing scaffold of
writing
Myanmar I joined forces with Aaron
hassanov an amnh research associate who
had been working there with feel and
with field assistance people and
otete win to interview Spirit mediums
and Carvers this was a very very brief
incident but it helped to round out the
picture
and then in Bali I have had the pleasure
of working with Dr niwayan pasek ariati
a scholar of religious history and a
veteran field worker who will also be
participating in the ey Yale conference
just to bring everything home
in Korea I have usually been a solitary
Anthropologist working sometimes with a
field assistant but I was learning the
pleasures of teamwork especially when
different people have different kinds of
expertise
and when I returned to the question of
the Fallen paintings I joined forces
with Dr Jones a folklorist and Dr yotsu
Yoon an art historian both of whom have
had interesting things to say about
Shaman paintings
both of them now have private museums
with extensive collections
and ties in in you know that
complemented Mai Tais all of these
collaborations produced co-authored
papers in English language professional
journals and a co-authored book on
Shaman paintings
these were cited pieces in the patchwork
quilt that would become mediums and
magical things the 2021 book
and because it had worked so well for me
in Vietnam when I met with Carvers in
Myanmar I would use the story of the
paintings that had fought with each
other and fell to the floor in my
conversations there
and also with Carvers in Bali
I came to imagine this project as a
wide-ranging vicarious dialogue between
conversation Partners in different
places who have never met face to face a
Carver in Vietnam told me this I would
say a mask vendor in Bali told me that
in a South Korean Shaman Shrine the
paintings fought with each other and
fell to the floor
I approach this work
through three affordances affordances
like
um you know you think of the handle on
the coffee cup there are all different
kinds of coffee cups all different
shapes
um but they're you know a simple single
operation that helps bring the cup to
one's lips
and that's how I approached different
ways people had of talking about how
they make and enliven these images
from the field of material religious
studies calls for a deeper appreciation
of the process of fabricating religious
things and this is my first affordance
of most direct entrance for a
conversation about active matter and its
spiritual implications and this is an
affordance that spans what we might
think of as the Catholic World
originating but no longer by any means
restricted to Europe and the East and
you know but Europe and the Eastern
Mediterranean originally
and the Hindu Buddhist world that you
know way across all of Eurasia more or
less
throughout this vast Eurasian Geographic
span we find places where religious
images have long traditions of Workshop
production where they have been
commissioned as acts of conspicuous
devotion and produced to a higher level
of skill
where levels of material consumption
enable standards and hierarchies of
value with respect to materials and
craft those who commission install and
subsequently venerate sacred images are
dependent or or well in the Catholic
word we don't say venerate the images
but you know offer prayers and sincerity
inspired by the statues
but all right in both instances the
Catholic World the Hindu Buddhist world
in the first instance these things are
being made in workshops they're not
you're not fabricating your individual
personal religious object
and the critical work then has been
entrusted to other hands
but and this is my second affordance now
we slice that first affordance in half
significant difference between religious
statutes in a Catholic tradition and
religious statues in a Hindu or a
Buddhist tradition appreciating that
these are multiple traditions
Catholic images are considered
sacramentals they Inspire prayer they
enable the reception of Grace but they
are not or are not supposed to be idols
when they show signs of Life they are
considered yeah this is a weird thing
this is miraculous
and or theologically problematic
instances of statues weeping flying
around sweating uh Inspire very serious
religious investigation
in the Hindu Buddhist world images are
made to be inhabited gods or Buddhas as
you saw in the slide of the Vietnamese
Carver at work and there's a cavity in
the back
images in the Hindu Buddhist world are
regarded as presences consecrated and
venerated through appropriate techniques
and practices sacred powerful sometimes
dangerous but also material objects that
will deteriorate over time
in these places the relative quality of
materials of craftsmanship and some
practices we might cautiously and
heuristically call Magic are
consequential for the image's subsequent
career as an insoled and agent of thing
consequential for its efficacy or
absence thereof
the final affordance in my 4K studies
that fall under the very broad umbrella
of sacred images in a larger Asian world
are those distinctive traditions of
mediumship and Showmanship that work in
conjunction with the gods or spirits
that possess Spirit mediums and are
manifested or are manifested by shamans
a doubling of the well-crafted image and
the mobile body as in a Korean court so
three affordances there's Workshop
production to a high degree of quality
there's the notion that the statue
contains is made to be unsold
insole through ritual practices can also
be de-installed
and finally there are specific
traditions where the images work in
conjunction with a shaman or a medium
we'll say something about how
why okay this happens in lendon in
Vietnam
this happens in Nutley in Myanmar
and in the Balinese odalan the temple
festivals the mask image covers and
subsumes the identity of the medium a
blending of image and mobile body when
the deity appears in Temple festivals
my work I want to emphasize thinking of
that unfortunate chapter 8 of my first
book this is not going to be a
controlled comparison as will become
evident it was the unexpected answers to
otherwise legible questions that made
things interesting
in the carving workshops of the Red
River delta of Vietnam I learned the
importance of craft using properly
seasoned wood and working it with a
knowing hand a knowledge of tradition a
Clear Vision in the Mind's Eye to make a
proper image I think thus far you know
any sculptor would probably say that
not just good wood and excellent skill
though but in the most traditional
workshops attentions to things we might
consider Magic
the wood is cut on an auspicious day and
hours set by the lunar Almanac after
sending out any ghosts or odds or
unofficial
infolicitous elements that might have
taken up residence inside the old wood
and the Carver who makes the cuts is
endowed with a horoscope that sinks
properly with the year day month and
hour the wood is cut to an auspicious
measure on the scheme attributed to
luban the Chinese god of carpentry
the master Carver seeks a vision of the
intended deity in his own Mind's Eye
before he begins to carve he makes his
workers observe various Workshop taboos
no bare chests no inauspicious talk no
laundry hanging over the statue no
menstruating women touching the statue
no dog meat consumed no garlic or strong
smelling herbs when the final gilding is
applied
offerings and and petitions punctuate
the entire process from the master
Carver's offerings to the goddess before
going to discuss the commission to a
with a potential Patron to the patrons
final inspection of the Finnish statue
and request of the goddesses permission
to bring it to the home Temple
um
in this process it becomes difficult to
parse the difference between the
strictly material practices and things
done for other reasons other
consequences and I want to note when I
speak about magic in Vietnam or Korea or
anywhere these places are not strangers
to modern science this is something else
the statues like the communion host are
material things whose intended work
overflows material logic a statue will
be less efficacious even inauspicious
where the Carver substitutes cheap
Branchwood for more durable core wood
we're improperly seasoned with rots or
becomes infested with insects where the
Artisan skimps on the gold lacquer
commissioned by the patron or where the
product is simply a Lee
if human beings do not punish the Carver
the God's Will said one master Carver
who considers his own work his
scrupulous attention to all these
details as doing the mother goddess's
work
of course not all images are equally
efficacious nor are they all made with
the same care
a shopkeeper on hanoi's hankwat Street a
hive for these activities described a
hierarchy of value she said the least
expensive the least and the least
efficacious in her view statues are the
ones that are just sort of chunked out
you know so many types of the tenth
Prince and they're all on the shelf and
you come in and you buy one
the next are commissioned through the
shopkeeper yeah I wanted 10th Prince and
they're made to a they're more expensive
they're made a little better they might
work a little better she said and then
the best are the statues made by a
master Carver using all of the
traditional processes I've been talking
about and these of course are the most
if expensive and the most efficacious
statues like those that had been gifted
to the Vietnam Museum of ethnology had
been made according to all the
procedures for making but the process
had stopped there they then were not in
Seoul but they could have been
younger mediums use less expensive
statues
and they they will say oh a statue's a
statue it's the ritual master who puts
the god inside you just need a good
ritual master
but the older mediums associated with
established temples will say oh that's
naive that's that's even dangerous
assuming that badly made statues are not
Ling do not secure the mother goddesses
favor and will bring inauspicious
consequences
um I would find this kind of argument
about what you have to do no you don't
have to do that in other places as well
and I see this this is kind of a
dialogic practice it is important to
point out the disagreements that living
people have when it's a living tradition
and this is a symptom of how how real it
all is where the marketplace offers a
range of Market choices even for the
images of Gods
now Myanmar is also in the Buddhist
world
and
um albeit terravada not Mahayana and
with a different ritual calendar
but from what I had read uh before going
there in 2011 images are also animated
nut Spirits are invested with the nuts
butterfly soul and live in close
association with Spirit mediums who
carefully tend them bathe them dress
them note the arrangement in the basket
they've arrived at the festival and now
the statues have not been piled inside
the basket which would be more
protective would also be an economy of
space no the nuts should see where we're
going so they're out
yeah
um
the uh I had been curious about the
Burmese nut play for a very long time
again this is another kind of ritual
where like the Korean shamans could like
the lindong it's richly costumed the
gods appearing in this sequence of
incarnation that accompanies costuming
and departure de costuming and on
through a sequence I wanted to see in
terms of this project if the workshops
that carve the medium small wooden
images were attentive to both magic and
craft as their counterparts in Vietnam
might be
I learned that in Myanmar mediums carry
their own images with them to rituals as
their co-present enablers and to
festivals in the nuts home temples where
the little images are periodically
irradiated by their presence to the
source statutes the original seats of
the nut
um this is a more portable practice than
the immobile stat in Vietnam the ritual
Master sets it on the Altar and if you
know one medium told me she was dusting
and she knocked it a little Askew and
she had pain in her arms and so on and
so forth until she got a ritual master
and just said it right again but no
these are quite mobile the they go with
them with the
um
nut jaw the mediums and they get a bit
banged up
ethnographies of Myanmar describe their
battered condition I didn't see batter I
saw as in Vietnam a moment where people
could afford to re-guild their images
and things were looking pretty good
when we spoke to the Carvers near the
mahamuni Pagoda in Mandalay and the
schwedigon Pagoda in Yangon
Carvers were familiar with our questions
yes the Carver should abstain from
alcohol and work with a clean body and a
respectful attitude shoes removed as in
a pagoda or a monastery and yes the
statues must be beautifully carved
according to a proper prototype a ritual
offering might Mark the start of a large
and important commission and depending
on the client's willingness to pay a
Carver would observe different levels of
Buddhist precept
but we soon realized that our interest
in nut images was confusing to the
Carvers the Carvers we were talking to
who considered the nut a sideline the
Buddha images were where it was really
happening
and when they describe prohibitions and
purifications they were largely
referencing carving a Buddha for a major
Temple Commission
in addition the form of a Buddha image
demands strict adherence to precise
protocols set down in texts while not
images need only approximate the
gestures and con
um costumes deployed by mediums and
sometimes a medium will see the nut in a
particular gesture in a dream and that
becomes the gesture of the image
um
and one Carver said he felt happier when
carving the Buddha because he could
focus his whole mind on it the Nazi said
could be rougher and cruder than a
well-finished Buddha image I've I have
since heard that there are there is a
special fraternity of not Carvers who do
take the carving very seriously but
um they they're a small small corner on
the supply it's like in Vietnam are you
going to buy a very elegant statue are
you going to buy a lesser but there
seemed also to be a bit of a difference
between mother goddess figures in
Vietnam and nut figures in Myanmar
there's such a very clear
hierarchization
the Buddha is absolutely Central and the
nuts are something else again nuts
our
relative to the Buddha that they died
most of them died violently they died
through treachery or otherwise badly
these are not spiritual people or
spiritual entities in dying they were
unable to assume a prayerful orientation
toward the next life they were denied
reincarnation
as Burma Scholars describe them nuts
remain trapped in the emotions and
appetites they bore while alive
where good Buddhists work towards
salvation by periodically following
precepts and joining moral Behavior
fasting Temperance and other austerity
the nuts exemplify the appetites and
failings of the Flesh in the stories
told about them the corporeal activities
they enact via their mediums and the
Rowdy and transgressive behaviors of
roistering devotees on the periphery of
nut festivals
but unlike the Transcendent Buddha nuts
are the guys to whom you bring your
mundane concerns your love affairs your
business your gambling aspirations you
don't you just don't bother the Buddha
with that it's it's totally improper but
the nuts are there for you so they get
taken care of
not images are of course
deeper the wood is of less quality they
can even be made out of plastic although
when I was in Myanmar it would be
virtually impossible to find a Buddha
image made
plastic
this is not an argument that the images
are necessarily shabby they're as nice
as the medium can afford and it's not an
argument that like some traditions
they're intended to Decay no they're
supposed to last as long as they
possibly can rather the accessibility of
and portability of these images is a
reflection on the accessibility of the
nuts themselves
the
acquisition is a personal rather than a
community project the way commissioning
a Buddha image would be and these small
and relatively inexpensive images
circulate freely little not are
carefully tended by their medium and
quaffed in at least some cases with the
medium's own hair
now
I was ready to go back to Korea and
learn more about the images of gods that
had been fighting and fell to the floor
of course once we turn to the Munchen
Shrine we're talking not about Statue
bodies but about two-dimensional
paintings on laminated paper and
sometimes even cheap garish mechanically
reproduced prints
now I knew that when Munchen install
Buddha images on their Alters this is a
relatively recent practice they mimic
Buddhist eye-opening rituals or higher
monks to do this for them
in and the in the Buddhist World
animation of Animation the container of
a statue a body has a liturgical
certainty you do the ritual properly and
it should happen it should be enlivened
so long as the procedures are carried
out correctly
but when I asked how the gods enter the
paintings
I encountered a certain vagueness
we cause the gods to be there one
Munchen said and no there's no special
ritual for this the gods go into the
paintings the manchin needs them to be
there in order to receive inspiration in
the form of bright energy what they call
myungi and this is supposed to happen
when the Munchen sees them in front of
her eyes as part of the initiation
ritual
I realized that back in 1989 Diana Lee
and I had actually captured such a
moment in our film and I will share this
with you
again
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
questions
foreign
up there and nothing had happened that
really would have been a disaster
um
and uh
in the beginning he said what's happened
here she has told her you have to act
like a god to feel the inspiration to be
the God and then it it comes through and
she's told go in go into your Shrine and
you know now you know bow and that
connection is established the gods have
taken their seats in the paintings
oops like much in Shaman practice though
it is all a bit ambiguous it's not like
you do the ritual the God's there the
statue encloses it in fact the the
painting is conceptualized something
like a seat and a God can get up from
that seat
the gods might not at bribe at all and
the initiation might fail and the
paintings go back to the shop or a
charlatan Munchen performs as though the
gods were present in the paintings but
the paintings are empty and only the
other man should know this
or the gods might arrive but they don't
have the force to really make the shaman
an effective shaman as alas that was the
case in the segment you just saw that
poor young woman she just didn't have
enough inspiration to get up the next
day and be a shaman speaking on behalf
of clients and
um
she had to work at it further
um this is an ongoing relationship too
the gods are in the paintings but it's
ongoing it's like a marriage you know
they they might have a falling out
the transmission of inspiration through
the paintings might turn staticky
because the shaman has done something
that displeases the gods as when
yongsu's mother offended her own Gods by
bringing in her sister's gods and she
said and I pray to them and I used to
get this clear flow of inspiration but
when that was going on it was just
static
um or once present Gods might depart in
a fit of peak just leave utterly leaving
the Munch into silence no voice no
dreams No Visions no body cues or other
intuition sometimes the Munchen can make
it right again as youngsu's mother did
and sometimes not
some Munchen and the very few
traditionalist painters who remain in
South Korea consider the careful
production of a painting the painter
engaging with the Shaman's vision and
observing Workshop protocols that would
be legible in the carving workshops in
Vietnam and Myanmar and Bali as
essential to the flow of inspiration
through the painting it is said that the
paintings by Mr on whom you see in this
picture have a very high success rate
when they are used in initiation rituals
and this man has more work than he can
handle I interviewed Mr Ahn and another
traditionalist painter both of whom
claimed that they sat with a Munchen
until they could share her vision yeah
what did you see was what color was the
robe what gesture was the hand and when
they both feel confident that the the
painter can reproduce it and then they
they bathe they report to the gods and
Buddhas before beginning their work they
live like monks for the duration of the
Commission in isolation and austerity
Mr Ahn said I just don't go outside I
might see an accident I might see a
quarrel and that would affect the
painting the whole spiritual connection
to the project
and both painters related wondrous Tales
of their engagements with gods and
paintings Munchen who could afford their
work considered these paintings a mark
of Distinction and good practice
but in truth in South Korea most Munchen
used paintings that are either produced
in commercial workshops or the
commercial prints when pressed on this
point even Munchen who are proud of
their own traditionally produced very
expensive paintings will give Primacy to
the munchen's connections to the gods a
Munchen with strong hobby strong
compatibility with the gods draws them
to the paintings and makes them want to
stay there and even some mention she
said could work even with a photograph
the shaman Fosters a good relationship
with her Gods through her own daily
devotions this is her responsibility and
she makes pilgrimages to sacred
mountains to recharge her spiritual
batteries this is an analogy that they
use themselves there was a lot of
electricity talk in these interviews
um I came to see the munchen's body the
shrine and the mountain as something
like electrical circuitry the Munchen
transmitting back from the mountain to
the shrine to the gods seated in the
images who provide a steady flow of
inspiration in the form of words bodies
bodily Sensations dreams Visions or
probably most often just very sharp
intuition
not a fixed container like the statue
the painted image is also more fragile
mutable they become soiled with incense
and candle Smoke and are sometimes
gnawed on by bugs or rats
gods in the Munchen World prefer Pure
Clean things when the shaman can afford
to replace them the gods are politely
told can you abandon your seat for a
minute and we they take the painting
down burn it and replace it with a nice
clean one and invite the gods back
while statues are tenderly repaired the
painting is in effect treated like an
old skin
paintings from the shrine of a retiring
Shaman if not passed to a successor
would be buried with the rest of her
paraphernalia in a mountain grave we do
this for people and we do this for them
too she meant the gods
um a Munchen explained that the proper
disposition of part of departed Gods
enacted through the medium of paintings
rotting corpse-like in the ground
although of course the paintings had the
gods had been asked to leave the
paintings before they were buried
this lack of fixity this absence of
liturgical certainty this ultimate
Reliance on the variable powers of the
munchin to draw the God's inspiration
through the painting suggests to me a
distinction between the Korean Munchen
as a shaman herself a master of the
spirits fully agentive
in contrast with the omdong and badong
of Vietnam the next jaw of Myanmar also
for who for the most part experienced
trance is more passive vehicles of the
Divine the equivalent of the statue
container
in other words by looking outside of
Korea and then coming back to Korea
again I saw a productive contrast that
affirmed my sense of what Korean shamans
are
um the success of a quote is very much a
matter of the connection between the
Munchen and her Gods if she enjoys her
favor and if for Gods themselves are
powerful then they send her good
inspiration her manifestations her
compelling clients laugh and weep in the
presence of gods and ancestors and
receive uncannily accurate or at least
experientially resonant divinations the
favor that the Munchen receives is
transmitted to the favor that the client
receives and the quote is a success the
Shaman's own identity and reputation are
closely identified with a success or
failure of the quote she performs now as
an elaboration of this point here is a
brief contrast with the expectations of
a Divine manifestation by Munchen in a
Korean and the spirit entities who
inhabit masks worn by Spirit mediums in
Temple festivals in Bali
in Bali local tutelary Gods the sesu
Hunan go to ground in Temple masks that
have been carefully carved and ritually
animated according to exacting protocols
very similar to what I've been talking
about The Masks of particular temples
gain renown
has particularly powerful Hunan
this is Judo America
Hunan who resides in the private Temple
of the former rulers of Ubud the mask is
famous for propelling General America a
medium well through the medium the mask
on the medium on Long itinerating
Journeys around and Beyond the town of
Ubud to neutralize practitioners of
black magic to protect the town
I saw Judo America in action once and
heard many accounts of other occasions
the medium was in the innermost
Courtyard on that one occasion when I
was present the medium was meditating
and it was told to me by people who was
there that ahead of schedule the medium
is inspired puts on the mask comes down
to the temple Courtyard does a few turns
and then runs out of the temple followed
by all these these guys who've been
waiting for this moment and they go for
the next several hours all through the
streets of Ubud and it all get and
people fall into very violent trance it
all gets posted on social media and
um you know as was related to me by the
people in my hotel who knew where I had
been the night before
um
so I wanted to of course I wanted to
interview the medium and using a field
assistance connections with the interior
of the Palace of Ubud we were given a
name of the spirit medium who we were
told had done the ritual and we spent
the better part of a day tracking him
down we chased and chased he was here no
he was there and then finally we got a
hold of him
um and he said no that wasn't me they
thought it was me because I'm a famous
guy but that wasn't me that was somebody
else now that would never happen with a
Munchen and a quote it's her court and
the gods working through her in Bali
it's the sesu Hunan who've gone to
ground in the mask and it's the mask
much more than the medium albeit the
medium is not inconsequential but that
really makes it happen
um
okay so in conclusion the aim of this
journey has not been to make a typology
or God forbid a particularly Asian
interpretation rather it is to present a
wide-ranging conversation enabled by
some broad general principles about
materiality and Magic among mediums and
shamans Carvers and painters in my four
examples as I move through them things
learned in one place could be
productively upended in another domain
of popular religious practice statute
workshops in Vietnam introduced the idea
of statue making as an unfolding of
craftsmanship protocol and Magic to
produce an efficacious agent if object
the Myanmar example offered a variation
on the theme that images are made more
casually and at less cost material
conditions that reflect the nuts
subordination to the Buddha and the
general accessibility and portability of
not
when these Carvers would see something
of themselves in the Burmese in
Vietnamese counterparts
paper images in Korean Shaman shrines
counter the gravitas of the statue
container with a more ambiguous Spirit
presence that Witnesses the gods more
fluid and dynamic relationship with the
munchin the importance of the munchen's
own agency in sustaining the flow of
inspiration something I would not have
appreciated to the same degree had I not
used what I had learned in Korea to make
questions posed in other places that
generated questions and some surprising
answers back in Korea less a comparison
than a dialogue
and speaking of dialogue I want to end
this presentation with an expression of
gratitude to my research partners and to
all of you for staying with me through
this rather long presentation thank you
thanks so much this was
to say the least
um
please excuse my ignorance in advance
but um
who once a statue is in Seoul
as does the spirit stay in it or does it
leave and then there's another there's a
need for another ritual to call it back
and does it depend on where the statue
is let's say it's it's in the temple
therefore the spirit stays
um could you Enlighten us on on this as
I understand it all the activity around
the statue around the mask around the um
uh well in the three places that use
carved wooden objects is on the
assumption that the deity should stay
now
um there are occasions where again the
deity is sent away you need to repair
your statue
and there are special permit special
protocols for that there's also some
disagreement you know do you have to do
a full Decon de-sacralization if you are
just going to repair it inside the
temple versus taking it to the Carver's
Workshop you know these little
nitty-gritty things that people do argue
about I heard stories
um in a particular one of the story one
of the encounters that got me interested
in all of this a village where during an
anti-superstition campaign they were
ordered to take the statutes down and
throw them in the village Pond and women
describe praying you know please leave
and please forgive us it's the
government that's doing this it's not us
it's their fault and um you know to
enable the gods to depart there are
stories throughout the Hindu Buddhist
world there's some understanding that as
in the Catholic a Catholic statue loses
its blessing if it's bad hanged up and
that's you know that's not an
Incarnation that's just you know a
special Grace state in this world where
the gods are there there is also some
sense that if it's banged up and
disrespected the gods leave
but that's you know that deals that's
has to do with the inadequacy of the
material container
um or I guess you know true acts of
desecration like iconoclastic moments so
that that's that's an interesting
comment whereas in Korea you know if
they go up they go down it's it's a much
less permanent thing because it's the
relationship that has to constantly be
reaffirmed
um hi thank you so much for coming this
is so interesting I was wondering if you
had like maybe like a personal
experience with Korean Shamanism because
I'm assuming you're in close proximity
to it and I wonder if you had the
opportunity to experience maybe
contacting your own ancestors
out of curiosity
well through the shamans yes
I've I have sponsored quote for the dead
on behalf of my parents
and I've been addressed by my dead
parents who speak much better Korean
than I do and but you know with some
americanisms like okay thrown in
um I had one one of those Twilight
experiences where
um when my father was Ill with cancer I
remember him touching my back and saying
oh I can feel your ribs and me thinking
you shouldn't be worried about my weight
we're we're all worried about your
weight and
um then when we were doing
a response I sponsored a ritual after
his death and the shaman comes up
incarnating manifesting my father and
feels my back and said okay be yeah
you're I can feel your bones I could
feel your ribs
and I thought oh this is weird you know
how did she you know this is
um and I thought it's all in my head I
imagined it but no Diana Lee got it on
film
I can't say all of my encounters are
that Vivid but that one that that one
stands out for me
thank you for the fascinating talk I I
um found myself having lots of different
thoughts about different things I've
seen over the years that I realized now
I probably didn't understand and my
question may well reveal just how did I
understand
um but um I was thinking about stupas
and Relics
and the way
um even uh so in the beinecke library
here we have the hakumanto darani and my
understanding of the efficaciousness of
the darani was that they were supposed
to be the words spoken by the Buddha and
so I was thinking about how all of that
works and whether there are connections
there and then it also led me to
thinking about the question of mummies
so instead of what we would consider
an inanimate object being animated
you have the kind of opposite where what
we would have once considered to be
inanimate object seems no longer to be
and yet
continues to be revered as if still
alive
um sorry I'm revealing my own prejudices
here with the way I'm saying that but
you know and I'm just wondering if you
see connections there more generally
across
North and Southeast Asia as well okay
mommy's I will say I know pretty much
zero are you talking about those
traditions where like a Taoist is
supposed to eat a certain kind of wood
and then their body is preserved from
putrification or I was thinking mainly
of
um quoasan and kukai who's supposedly
still alive
um and every day the monks bring him his
food and he's
[Music]
supposedly sitting there meditating
hundreds of years later
um
so so I I I'm sorry I'm not very
coherent this is not really a question
yeah no it's interesting I mean these
are all topics for you or your students
to take on these are um you know
this is all under the banner of material
religion
there you know as as I you may know some
people know my students get very upset
when people use the word object because
they've all taken a course on thing
Theory and if it's not an artifact you
call it a thing because it's so much
more than just the material limitations
of what it is and there are so many
things that could be studied to you know
how do people think about them how do
people argue about what they're supposed
to think about them what's the proper
care and feeding of such an object and
uh you know it's there are
infinite examples there's all kinds of
interesting work that can be done with
respect to the mummy
I guess the the thing most resonant to
me is what is it about the human form
these are all you know in one instance
the mask it's just the head with the
medium body but the others are all what
does it mean to replicate a human form
does it conjure a presence
Museum mannequins people have all these
Night at the Museum responses to them
because they're human forms and human
sizes not like big statues on pedestals
a lot there's it's just it's just a big
sea that you know to jump in and swim in
and get more from
thank you um
I I I know nothing about the spiritual
world so it was really eye-opening for
me to see that world through
things as you did and no I had this
preconceived concept that the spirit
mediums had this special connection to
the spiritual world and the objects as
supplements to the world but the way you
painted is how the no one including the
mediums can reach the spiritual world
alone and actually they need the objects
or paintings to be get inspired
therefore it's the covers or painters a
critical part of of the efforts and how
incredibly communal that effort is and
how it is not an individual relationship
to the spirituality and I imagine that
that communality or the how the belief
the spiritual relationship is only
possible through the communal Collective
efforts is heightened and highlighted
through rituals but I was wondering in a
mundane everyday settings
how the kind of collective relationality
to spirituality manifests
perhaps differently or how how that no
just
practiced or felt in that moment when
that's not enough you know spiritual
performative moment okay that's a very
good question thank you I mean these
these different
representations inhabit different
sociality social worlds
um I in the case of the Korean shamans
every day they in the morning they burn
candles they offer water this is so you
know and they address their deities
and then there is this kind of playful
ongoing the shaman receives a gift it
goes first onto the Altar and it's
Essence gets consumed by the deities and
then she takes it back sometimes
there'll be a dream one of the deities
in the Munchen I worked with most
closely one of the deities was was in ha
was the person appointed to be that
deity was her dead husband who had been
an alcoholic and every now she described
one incident where she gets this wild
craving for Korean soju and has to run
to the store and put all the bottles
under the painting and
so no it is ongoing it is daily but it's
it's in the more intimate sphere of one
practitioner and her deities or in
Myanmar The the daily tending of these
little images it's it's almost like
doll-like devotion but I didn't want to
talk about dolls because it's so
freighted with psychological
stuff that I didn't want to impose on on
the
Burmese Spirit mediums but no
um no it's it is it is a sense of
continuous presence it's just that in
the ritual moment then the deity becomes
manifest in the medium or the shaman and
that's it but the communities are
different when you make uh say a
Buddhist image in a village community in
Myanmar it's the whole Community working
on it when you um
well you know feeding the Carvers and
maybe doing some Buddhist precepts to
help everything along when you carve a
mask in a Balinese Community the
community is feeding the Carver and and
there are members of the community who
are in the temple meditating before the
carving starts and there's this great
sense of collective Enterprise
the shaman work and I would say the
nachos work is much more individualistic
oriented in terms of the relationship on
the one hand and the administrative
clients who are bringing their own
special problems in
thank you so much for such a fascinating
talk I guess my question is sort of
remaining in the mundane World a little
bit and just thinking about what happens
in a couple of cases when
these objects are removed from their
communities and so you described you
know these are there is a market
in some sense or another for these
objects and you know the more you pay
the better the efficacy
um
what happens I mean I feel like these
days you can go to any kind of
um
Garden Center or whatever and pick up a
statue of a Buddha yeah and I wondered
how your interlocutors feel about this
use of these kinds of statues and then
on a more serious note
what are the implications and I'd just
love to hear you talk a little bit about
what happens when these objects become
curated in museums and and how do you
negotiate those kinds of
um
there's to the last part of your
question
I could I could do a whole hour on that
but
um and and there's a range of stuff
there are most of what ends well no I
can't
museums are getting more Savvy and
sensitive now there's writing for
example on uh if it's a consecrated
Tibetan image do you you can image it do
an x-ray and see if it has consecration
material in it if it has the
consecration material in it is it still
carrying the charge or not
um do you call in a Tibetan monk to
maybe revivify it or remove it or deal
appropriately with it
it's at least as varied as the stuff I
was talking about in answer to the last
question museums are doing different
things in different ways but over the
last 30 years we have seen a huge uptick
in the sensitivity of museums to the
prior lives and meanings of the material
in our our care in the American Museum
of Natural History we have deep in our
storage something we call the smudge
room
and it's a room where among other things
Native Americans can come in take sweet
grass and purify objects and it won't
set off the smoke detector it along the
fire service will only respond to heat
and it's also been used by Tibetans it's
been used by visiting Siberians it's
it's a special space set apart the
museum made that commitment to
recognizing these needs
um so oh no there are lots and lots and
lots of stories that can be told about
Museum responses to the sacredness of
objects and I would say it's a it's a
growing Consciousness when we did our
new northwest coast Hall you would walk
down the anthropology court or you know
the non-public space and on the door of
one of the conservators areas if this
room contains shamanic objects they may
be dangerous to certain persons Please
be aware
and then the empowered things were
covered when they weren't being worked
on and it became a kind of laboratory
culture that developed in consultation
with the people who were The Descendant
community
and we all love it I mean this is
anthropology comes home full circle
and then what was the first question
non-religious use of non-religious use
yeah I think again you would find a huge
range from the people who say well it
wasn't made to be sacred so who cares to
the people who are saying that's not
that's disrespectful and that's
disturbing and that's only going to
bring bad luck
I mean just you know just a range of
stuff the what I've looked at and I do
mention a bit in the book is things that
fall into the Art Market and when where
and how that happens
and you know the stories that might
arise around that and some shamans who
say well they know the gods know that
you know the shop isn't for them the
museum isn't for them they take off but
um and with the Statue some general
assumption again that they have been
deactivated and some dealers who will
treat things with respect I'd never put
it on the floor it goes on a Shelf
can I say can I ask you a little more
about the materials going in the niches
in the back of a statutory I know a lot
of work's been done in Chinese Buddhism
for what's in can you say a little bit
about the relationship in different
countries or different figures between
what goes in and the type of ensolvement
or efficacy or anything like on that
line okay they will say I mean what what
I've heard
is that even within Vietnam it's highly
variable
I haven't heard in Vietnam for example
of putting but you know and then you
compare and it's variable
um
but in general it's five precious metals
or substances it's sometimes five
colored strings you know the colors of
the cosmos and that it's some people say
that's the intestines a lot of amuletic
material
sometimes metal I have seen the
Interiors the stuff come out of Tibetan
statues that includes even things like
watch bearings because they were
probably the right metal but I don't
know for sure I have heard in well
there's been a lot of work done on this
catch of statues in China that contain
various Materia Medica related to the
work the statue is supposed to do
in Taiwan sometimes poisonous bugs and
insects and then some people say but
that's never for a Buddha that's for the
ones that are supposed to help you in
business now
aggressive
so no highly variable but recognizable
where people say oh yeah unlike me you
know what you put the stat you put stuff
in the Statue and bring it to life and
I'd never heard of it this is a very you
know comfortable acknowledgment across
the span that I've been talking about
uh so I'm interested in the combination
of statues in this picture I'm wondering
are they just a random bundle or like
are they combined together to add up to
the efficacy are they combined too they
are they not who have been identified as
working with a particular medium
on the basis of dreams on the basis of
The Nut Job goes to a festival and the
music for a particular nuts played and
he or she dances wildly and they say oh
you've got to observe them and then they
they get an image at some point and the
Quest for the Perfect Image can be quite
interesting too there are different
stories about how finding the right
statue
okay um well then I just asked the last
question a more broader question about
Shamanism and then we can close the the
event
um
so uh do you think Shamanism is on the
rise now because I think
oh gosh
one to five
if you had asked the reverse question do
I think it's dying out now it's
irrelevant I'd say absolutely absolutely
not okay yeah it seems to be flourishing
but uh you know you have to weigh that
against
um it's you know it's the degree to
which it had to be underground at
certain periods so is it more now or is
it just more out in the open I don't
know
there are organizations in South Korea
that claim they have statistics on
shamans I don't believe it they have
statistics on people who admit people
who've paid admission to a particular
Shaman organization there are many many
more I'm sure than the statistics but
people also fall out of the practice
even though they're not supposed to
um so I would just say yes there are
it's emphatically not on decline
because I'm teaching
in religion and culture course often
students say that their parents although
they are Catholic Christians they often
consult with fortune tellers and Shaman
so apparently
or that they are not revealed their
practice but definitely a lot of people
are practicing Shamanism and then and
there is also
also that might account for what seems
like more there are people who you know
40 years ago they would just call
themselves a fortune teller a diviner
and not a really initiated Shaman
nowadays I think the impulse is to cast
yourself as a shaman to even wear robes
and all even though whether or not you
know these old ladies that I worked with
would recognize the mishamans because
there's more cachet to it
agree on them though thank you so much
for your eliminating talk and thank you
so much for what's coming on
foreign
[Music]